elle vous fait entrer dans saint quentin
en yvelines depuis les années 90 la
porte de paris de piotr kowalski tout
proche du vélodrome et depuis le mois de
septembre
labellisé patrimoine d'intérêt régional
nous sommes à proximité de l'autoroute
a16 mais l'oncle idée des urbanistes à
l'époque plutôt d'avoir une simple
bretelle d'autoroute qui pénètre dans la
ville nouvelle
l'idée était d'avoir une véritable
entrée de ville marquer comme il se doit
avec cette arche monumental autour d'un
rond point qui permet de distribuer les
les différentes routes d'accès et
notamment l' axe qui se dirige tout
droit vers
vers la place le pompidou comme la porte
de paris deux autres avons obtenu ce
label lancé par la région en 2017
trois oeuvres qui ont un point commun la
monumentalité c'est à la fois
un label comme je disais de
reconnaissance et qui montre que ce que
cet art public
parti en patrimoine à part entière il
n'y a pas de fait finalement il n'y a
pas de petits et de grands patrimoines
et c'est aussi à la belle qui permet de
mettre l'accent sur cette particularité
des villes nouvelles de l'art public au
sein des villes nouvelles qui est quand
même une des caractéristiques assez
forte de ses oeuvres se parle avec un
fil conducteur la bièvre méthadone ici
mercado marque les débuts du canal
urbain une oeuvre de 92 qui appelle
celle de marta pan à guyancourt
la perspective qui est une oeuvre de
transition entre la ville et la campagne
et l'idée en fait des aménageurs à
l'époque de l'établissement public
d'aménagement était de concevoir ce
circuit d'eau en l'accompagnant
d'oeuvres d'art on a mis en place ce
qu'on appelle une étude préalable pour
autour de la perspective de martha panne
pour en étudier la restauration futur le
label permet une aide en investissement
pour la restauration et de
fonctionnement pour sa valorisation
saint quentin en yvelines possède 40
oeuvres d'art urbain l'agglomération
réfléchit à mettre en avant les oeuvres
du pôle elancourt maurepas